D
WORTH.
>> Laura: THANKS, BEN.
"GUTFELD!" NEXT.
>> THIS IS WHAT A CICADA LOOKS
LIKE WHEN IT'S COMING OUT OF THE
GROUND.
YOU'VE GOT ARTWORK OVER HERE AS
WELL.
ARE WE READY?
I'M LESS SCARED OF THIS.
OKAY.
>> OH, THE CRUNCH.
>> DO I HAVE A WING HANGING OUT
OF MY MOUTH?
>> Greg: CICADAS?
SHOULDN'T CNN BE EATING CROW.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW
IT IT'S TIME FOR?
>> HEY KIDS, IT'S TIME FOR
DEMOCRATS CORNER.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: WELCOME TO DEMOCRATS
CORNER.
WE ARE YOUR HOSTS, GREG GUTFELD,
GETS A QUICK HOST ON BASIC THING
STOP DEMOCRATS STOP RUINING YOUR
LIVES.
TONIGHT'S VERY SPECIAL EPISODE,
CAUSE AND EFFECT.
YOU ARE PROBABLY WONDERING WHAT
IS CAUSE AND EFFECT?
I'M A DEMOCRAT.
SIMPLY PUT, DEMOCRATS, IT'S WHEN
ONE THING MAKES ANOTHER THING
HAPPEN.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN CAT DRINKS TOO
MUCH TEQUILA.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> Greg: SHE DOESN'T GO TO
WORK THE NEXT DAY.
THAT IS CAUSE AND EFFECT.
THEN SHE STAYS HOME AND WATCH AS
FORENSIC FILES ALL DAY, WHICH
MAKES HER DEPRESSED.
CAUSE AND EFFECT.
THEN SHE STARTS ABUSING HORSE
TRANQUILIZERS.
CAUSE AND EFFECT.
WHICH IS HOW EYES SOLD ALL OF
THOSE HORSE TRANQUILIZERS.
CAUSE AND AMAZING EFFECT.
SEE, CAUSE AND EFFECT CAN LEAD
TO BAD THINGS IF YOU DON'T
CONSIDER THE CONSEQUENCES OF
YOUR ACTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU REMOVE
PUNISHMENT -- IF YOU PUNISH
CRIME, PRIME WILL GO AWAY.
BECAUSE OF CAUSE AND EFFECT.
YOU WILL PROBABLY SELL THIS
HORRIBLE ATTACK AT NYC, IT'S ONE
OF MANY.
THIS MANIAC WHO PUNCHED HER HAD
BEEN ARRESTED 17 TIMES, BUT BAIL
REFORM TODAY MEANS NO BAIL AND
NO JAIL.
IT IS CATCH AND RELEASE WITH
THEMES INSTEAD OF FISH.
THE UPSIDE, THE PRISONS AREN'T
OVERCROWDED.
THE DOWNSIDE, CHINATOWN
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE.
THAT'S CAUSE AND EFFECT.
CAUSE AND EFFECT EXAMPLE TWO,
MAYOR de BLASIO CUT 90 PLUS
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS MEANT
TO BUILD A NEW POLICE PRECINCT.
BECAUSE POLICE ARE BAD, EVEN THE
ONES THAT GUARD THE STUDIOS.
BUT IN THE LAST FIVE MONTHS, NYC
HAS HAD 531 SHOOTING.
I DO THE MATH, BUT I'M TOO
IMPORTANT FOR THAT.
SO NOW THE MAYOR IS REINSTATING
THE MONEY FOR THE PRECINCT.
WE COULD HAVE TOLD THEM THAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
WE ACTUALLY DID, BUT APPARENTLY
WE WERE DROWNED OUT BY THE
VOICES IN HIS LUMPY, GOOGLY EYED
HEAD.
CAUSE AND EFFECT, EXAMPLE THREE.
BALTIMORE MAYOR BRANDON SCOTT
ONCE PUSHED A DECREASE, NOW HE'S
PUSHING AN INCREASE.
WANT TO KNOW WHY?
HOMICIDES ARE UP 17%.
DEFUNDING REDUCE THE POLICE
FORCE AND MORE PEOPLE DIED.
PROBABLY MINORITIES.
BUT ADDITION AND SUBTRACTION IS
HARDER THAN CALCULUS.
WHAT DID WE PREDICT?
EXAMPLE FOUR.
PERIOD OF MORE FIRST-TIME IS.
ME INCLUDED.
IRONICALLY, DEMOCRAT MAYORS ARE
CAUSING ON SALES TO INCREASE FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" JUST
ADMITTED THIS, ROUGHLY ONE FIFTH
OF ALL GUN PURCHASES LAST YEAR
WERE FIRST TIMERS.
HAVE FOR WOMEN, OF FAITH WERE
BLACK, AND IF IT'S WORSE
HISPANIC.
AND THEY WERE YOUNGER.
I DO LOVE BUT HAVE THE NEW
PURCHASES WERE FROM WOMEN.
THE HIGHEST CONCERN FOR PURCHASE
WAS PERSONAL SAFETY.
APPARENTLY GUNS ARE NEAR THE NEW
SEAT BELTS IN 2021.
THAT'S LIKE CALLING MY PURSE A
MESSENGER BAG.
AFTER THE POLITICIANS AND MEDIA
DECIDED TO MAKE THE COMMUNITIES
LESS SAFE, IT'S UP TO YOU TO
PROVIDE YOUR OWN SECURITY.
A WHITE LIBERAL DOESN'T NEED A
GUN TO DO DAMAGE, ALL HE NEEDS
IS A POISONOUS IDEA AND A LITTLE
POWER AND IT WILL DESTROY
COMMUNITIES QUICKER THAN 5,000
DEMOCRATS MOVING TO HUNTSVILLE.
AND HE WILL DO IT WITHOUT AN
SECOND THOUGHT.
LOOK AT PORTLAND, OREGON, BUT
NOT FOR TOO LONG.
THE FLASH BANGS WILL BURN OUT
YOUR RETINAS.
ACCORDING TO BRIGHT PARK, ON MAH
MURDER OF THE YEAR, THAT'S FIVE
TIMES MORE THAN WERE REPORTED
DURING THE SAME.
BACK IN 2020.
THIS AFTER THE CITY COUNCIL CUP
THE POLICE BUDGET BY NEARLY 15%.
ACCORDING TO THEIR HAPLESS,
PATHETIC MARE WHO HAD TO FLEE HE
WAS HIS OWN CONDO, THEY HAD AN
85% DECLINE IN DOWNTOWN FOOT
TRAFFIC.
UNLESS YOU COUNT THE PEOPLE
RUNNING FOR YOUR LIVES.
MOST OF THE REMAINING TRAFFIC IS
SPEEDING, AND IT EVEN WHEN THEY
ARE ARRESTED THEY --
CAUSE AND EFFECT.
THIS SEEMS LIKE THE EASIEST
THING TO LEARN, BUT NOT A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT CAN.
JOE BIDEN CALLS THEM AN IDEA,
BEING ALLOWED TO DESTROY A CITY
WOULD DESTROY A CITY.
WE KNEW PUSHING THE DEFINED IN
THE POLICE AND BRANDING THEM
PSYCHOPATHS WOULD WEAKEN THE
FORCES AND LEAD TO EMBOLDEN
CRIMINALS AND MINORITY VICTIMS.
THEY BEAR THE BRUNT OF THIS.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO BE MISS CLEO
TO SEE THIS COMING.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
♪ ♪
>> THE LIBERAL ELITES?
[LAUGHS]
WILL LOOK, I'VE GOT TO SAY I
LIKE THEM OKAY.
I'VE GOT A LOT OF FRIENDS I
WOULD DESCRIBE THAT WAY AND THEY
ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
GOOD CONVERSATIONALISTS, THEY
LIKE WINE, BOOKS, GOOD MOVIE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
YES, I LIKE THEM.
BY THE WAY, I LIKE BABIES AND
PUPPIES TOO.
BUT I WOULDN'T PUT THEM IN
CHARGE OF THE CITY.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: HE IS WIDER THAN A
PAT BOONE FAMILY REUNION.
LET'S CHECK IN ON THE ANGRY
BLACK MALE.
♪ ♪
>> HEY, WHAT'S UP?
IF YOU DEFUND THE POLICE IN YOUR
CITY, THE CRIME WILL GO UP.
I'M NOT AN UPPER MALL ADJUSTER
ANYTHING, BUT I WANT TO KEEP
CRIME DOWN IN MY CITY.
IT'S A NICE DAY THOUGH.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO DEMOCRATS, THIS
HAS BEEN TODAY'S LESSON IN CAUSE
AND EFFECT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON
DEMOCRAT CORNER.
WE HOPE THAT YOU REMEMBER SOME
OF IT.
BUT I DIDN'T AND 78, BUT YOU
HAVE NO EXCUSE.
YES, WELCOME.
TONIGHT'S GUESTS, HE IS TO
ANSWER THE PRESIDENTS QUESTIONS
AND NOW SHE QUESTIONS THE
PRESIDENTS.
HE WAS ELECTED TO CONGRESS IN
25, THE SAME AGE I ACCOMPLISHED
RENTING A CAR, MADISON CAWTHORN.
HE'S LIKE A FENCE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
MY SIDEKICK, TYRUS!
ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING TO GO TO
YOU FIRST COME, CONGRESSMAN.
I'M PRETTY SURE -- YOU ARE IN
THE CLEAR AND CAT IS ONLY 21.
>> SEE, I LIKE THE SKY.
>> Greg: HE'S LIKE A BETTER
LOOKING VISION OF TOM BRADY.
>> WHEN I USED TO BE SINGLE I
WOULD KILL IT IN BOSTON.
>> DON'T GO TO TAMPA.
>> YOUR CONGRESSMAN, YOU DO WITH
REPUBLICANS ALL THE TIME, YOU
ARE A NEW MEMBER.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT CAUSE AND
EFFECT THAT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND?
>> I WOULD SAY WHEN YOU START
SEEING WHAT'S GOING ON IN
CONGRESS AND YOU CAN SAY THIS IS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, BUT
IT'S ALMOST ENTIRELY ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE AISLE.
THEY ARE RULED BY A SINGLE
PERSON EMBODIED BY NANCY PELOSI
WHO CARRIES OUT HER WELL WITH
THE NINE FIST.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THEY
FEEL IN THEIR HEARTS OR -- YOU
KNOW WHAT, MAY BE OUR RETINAS
WILL BE BURNED OUT WITH THE
FLASH BANGS.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT THEY
ARE MORE AFRAID OF LOSING THE
ELECTION AND NANCY PELOSI BEING
AGAINST THEM THAN THEY ARE DOING
THE RIGHT THINGS FOR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS, AND THAT IS WHAT
IS WRONG WITH CONGRESS.
>> KAYLEE, DO YOU AGREE WITH
THIS YOUNG TOM BRADY?
I ACTUALLY THINK -- EVEN THOUGH
THEY KNOW WE ARE RIGHT, MEANING
NONLIBERALS, THEY WOULD RATHER
LET PEOPLE SUFFER THAN BE SEEN
AGREEING WITH US.
IT'S LIKE A THE TRUMP OF FACT.
THE MOST PLAUSIBLE THEORY, BUT
YOU COULDN'T AGREE WITH HIM
BECAUSE HE WAS DRUNK.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
I DO AGREE WITH TOM BRADY.
WITHOUT A ASIDE, YES, THIS CAUSE
AND EFFECT.
YOU DEFUND THE POLICE, WHAT YOU
THINK IS GOING TO HAPPEN?
YOU LET CRIMINALS OUT OF PRISON
DURING A PANDEMIC, WHAT DID YOU
THINK WAS GOING TO HAPPEN?
HERE IS WHAT AMAZES ME.
THEY TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER AND
THEY SAY WE HAVE THE ANSWERS FOR
VIOLENT CRIMES, IT IS THAT THERE
IS A PANDEMIC AND EVERYONE IS
LOCKED INSIDE SO THEREFORE
MURDERERS HAVE GONE UP.
EXCUSE ME?
HOW DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
EVEN IN MEXICO MURDERERS WENT
DOWN.
BUT HERE IN THE UNITED STATES,
THEY ARE SKYROCKETING.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU LIKE
OUTNUMBERED SO FAR?
>> I LOVE IT.
I INVITED YOU WEEKS AGO.
>> Greg: I'M PICKING THE RIGHT
MOMENT.
>> WE WOULD THINK YOU ANY TIME.
>> Greg: AREN'T I A LUCKY GUY
JUST BEING HERE?
DON'T YOU THINK SO, TYRUS?
BY THE WAY, WHERE DID YOU FILM
ONE ANGRY BLACK MALE?
SPEAK I DON'T GIVE AWAY MY
LOCATION -- LET'S JUST SAY THE
HOTEL TREATS ME NICE.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH YOUR
MONOLOGUE, AND YOU KNOW I ALWAYS
LIKE YOUR MONOLOGUE, VERY RARELY
TO EVER DISLIKE YOUR MONOLOGUE,
BUT I JUST FEEL LIKE YOU ARE A
BAD GUY AND A MOVIE WHO IS
TRYING TO TELL MAY FORGET THE
PLAN, JUST GO SHOOT THEM.
YOU JUST DON'T GET IT, GREG.
YOU KEEP SAYING CAUSE AND
EFFECT.
ALL THEY UNDERSTAND HIS CAUSE.
AND THEY ALWAYS WANT CAUSES THAT
DON'T AFFECT THEM.
SO IT'S VERY EASY TO SAY IN A
REALLY NICE PLACE OR CONDO OR
PENTHOUSE OR WHEREVER YOU ARE
LIVING TALKING ABOUT WELCOME OF
COURSE.
WE DON'T NEED POLICE, I'VE GOT A
DOORMAN AND A SECURITY GUARD.
I DON'T NEED POLICE.
LET'S GET RID OF THEM.
THEY ARE NEVER AFFECTED BY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WORLD AND
THEN WHEN IT GETS TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY CAN SEE THE FIRE
BURNING FROM THEIR SPECIAL
VIEWING PLACE WHERE THEY SIPPED
THEIR WINE AND TALK ABOUT DAYS
OF OLD THEY NEVER CONTRIBUTED
THEN, THAT'S WHEN IT'S A
PROBLEM.
AND THEY ARE LIKE HEY, LET'S
REFUND THE POLICE.
THAT DOESN'T HELP BECAUSE MOST
OF THE OFFICERS HAVE LEFT TOWN,
RETIRED EARLY, AND WOULDN'T COME
BACK FOR DOUBLE THE WAGES.
SO -- OH, YOU'RE GOING TO FIX IT
AGAIN?
HERE'S ANOTHER THING, THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
VERY GOOD.
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY OH, NEW
INFORMATION, BREAKING NEWS, WE
JUST HEARD THAT THERE WAS A LAB
IN WUHAN THAT MAY HAVE DONE IT.
THIS IS CRAZY, WE NEVER KNEW
THIS.
AND THEN THE ONE REPUBLICAN ON
THE PANEL IS LIKE EXCUSE ME --
NO, NO, YOU ARE RACIST.
YOU CANNOT FIX PROBLEMS BECAUSE
THEY ARE JUST OUT OF TOUCH.
PELOSI ONLY CARES ABOUT GETTING
HER HAIR DONE AND MAKING SURE
HER ICE CREAM FREEZER IS FULL.
AS LONG AS SHE HAS ICE CREAM AND
A GOOD PERM, WE GOOD.
>> Greg: I WONDER IF SHE GETS
HERE AND THAT ICE CREAM.
>> BETWEEN THE DENTURES FALLING
OUT, MAY BE I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, KAT, I
THOUGHT THE HANGOVER WAS THE
BEST EXAMPLE OF CAUSE AND
EFFECT.
THEY HANG OVER, YOU DRINK TOO
MUCH, YOU PAY THE PRICE PAID
THAT'S EXACTLY LIKE VOTING FOR
DEMOCRATS.
IT MIGHT FEEL GOOD, BUT THEN --
>> I AM A RAGING ALCOHOLIC.
AND A HORSE TRANQUILIZER ADDICT
APPARENTLY.
>> Greg: DON'T FORGET THE
COMPUTER CLEANER.
>> YES, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, IT WAS SO EXCITING FOR A
LITTLE BIT THERE.
THESE MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS
WE WERE HAVING ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
THE REPUBLICANS WERE ON BOARD,
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS, IT WAS
EXCITING -- IT GOT EXCITING.
AND SOMETIMES WHEN THINGS GET
EXCITING, SOMEBODY HAS TO GO
FULL IDIOT.
LET'S LET VIOLENT FELONS WITH
REPEATED VIOLENCE AND ACTS OF
VIOLENCE IN THEIR PAST OUT OF
JAIL.
SO NOW WE ARE SEEING THIS AND
EVERYONE SAYING WELL, WHAT
HAPPENED?
IT'S QUITE OBVIOUS WHAT
HAPPENED.
THERE'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHEN A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM AND WANTING A TON OF
CRIME VIOLENT -- VIOLENT CRIME
ON YOUR STREETS.
I DO NOT LIKE VIOLENT CRIME.
I STAND STRONGLY AGAINST IT.
>> Greg: I'M NOT GOING TO SEE
WHERE YOU LIVE, BECAUSE I
TWEETED IT EARLIER.
BUT THERE ARE HOTELS IN PARTS OF
NEW YORK CITY THAT ARE FILLED
WITH FELONS.
AND -- BUT WE ARE TOLD THAT WE
SAY HOMELESS, BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS, BUT THEY
ARE HOMELESS BECAUSE THEY WERE
RELEASED FROM RIKERS, WHICH IS A
PRISON.
SO WE CAN'T SAY -- NO ONE SAYS
THEY ARE FELONS UNTIL THEY GO
OUT AND COMMIT A CRIME ON THE
STREET.
AND THAT YOU FIND OUT OH, THIS
GUY HAS BEEN ARRESTED EIGHT
TIMES IN THE PAST FOUR MONTHS
AND HE'S JUST GOING BACK IN AND
OUT AND IN AND OUT.
AND THAT'S THE SOLUTION.
WE'VE REACHED THE NADIR.